good morning Millennials but Friday
welcome back to the morning toast happy
Friday just like in the words of our
inspirational icon Rebecca Bach it's
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to going
home to New York who you everybody's
looking forward to coming to my show in
San Diego tomorrow night da go hey go
tickets available no jobs come Friday
I'm hitting up the Balboa theater in San
Diego Sunday two shows at the Regency
Ballroom in San Francisco can't wait to
see everyone there also if you're
watching this episode it means that all
my also if you're watching this episode
it means that the six shows I added are
now officially on sale Verona New York
Tarrytown Kansas City Kansas City
Ontario Margo what angle would New
Jersey a lot of shows were added that if
you weren't able to come to the New York
show at the beginning Stone Turning
Stone turn those stone you know Chucky
that's Verona please just like let me
finish the stupid [ __ ] ad okay if you
weren't able to get tickets to my show
in New York at the Beacon they're now
shows available in Englewood Verona and
Tarrytown I'm really looking forward to
it pre sell a lot of tickets sold but
there are still some available of course
where are they available go with their
job calm funny that you asked well today
if I really lost our my final day of LA
week and you know this town has really
gotten to us and it's mostly because as
we were saying before like we went so
hard this week we thirsted left right
and center and we tried really so hard
for everything and if only we tried this
hard at home like I think we'd be big
big stars with big big plant we see dead
you know
I'm gonna die like I have wrinkles on my
wrinkles I am so tired I cannot believe
I have to do three shows this weekend
and I did one last week and we did 1,700
podcast episodes every hundred this is
now our three of podcasting if you're
watching on YouTube like I'm not even
pretend like it's not about to happen
it's dark out takes just coming up soon
but we also recorded it with her 30
minutes ago because the timing didn't
work out so like we're just gonna and
you guys notice it's dark outside okay
like we're not gonna pretend I'm done
pretending la has made me an actress and
I don't like it but we're add to pretend
one more time because on Monday we have
the pot episode morning toast episode
with Lauren Elizabeth that we already
recorded that will
premiering on Monday podcast and video
it's gonna be so premium and so fun we
have a big big announcement we think you
guys already know what it is but it's
big fingers and rising and it's a secret
project special we just didn't want to
not have an episode on Monday because
I'm gonna be traveling back from San
Francisco where I have two shows at the
Regency Ballroom tickets available girls
no job hello instead you get a pre-taped
episode and now we're really LA
podcasters and now it's time to go home
now that we're like banking episodes
days in advance so you know we fly by
the seat of our pants on the show and
that's how we like it
honestly you know what now I feel like I
need to get a new business card because
I am officially a podcaster oh I knew
that I was a podcaster before this
because I have a podcast but after this
week like I am a podcast no and I feel
like we came to LA and like we
solidified with our podcast friends like
hey we are very much in the circle of a
podcasters because we hadn't been on all
these podcasts before so I'm gonna head
over to this and grant takes a podcast
to Noah pod Kappa to get a very
high-quality business card made that's
it
this is Claudia joy podcaster to the
Stars I think that's better
what about comedic podcaster that sounds
so like fake no that sounds like a
ninety-year-old CEO like comedic Custer
yeah yeah podcasting yeah everyone needs
a business card your next big
opportunity might be right now and
you're gonna be the idiot who doesn't
have a business card you're gonna be the
idiot um it's really easy to make a
business card I'm vistaprint you can
upload your own design if you're fancy
like that but if you're not and you're
like me they have tons of options when
it comes to designs different types of
paper quality things like you wouldn't
even think of like do I want like a
gloss shine or a matte shine I don't
know vistaprint tell me gloss for sure
you could pick the paper stock style and
quantity that's right for you and you
can even upgrade to unique touch like
rounded corners you'll order and receive
your cards with free economy shipping
you can feel good knowing that
Vistaprint uses only carefully selected
inks and responsibly sourced paper
stocks your satisfaction is a hundred
percent guaranteed or your money back
they wouldn't make it right 100 percent
in the words of vistaprint 100 percent
mr. Brent wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint.com enter
promo code toast for free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity it's a limited time offer so
make sure to own the now right now at
vistaprint.com and use the promo code
toast
Yushu wow talking is so hard you should
own now because why not because why not
we are not because if not now when if
not Jackie
Brister French contact you to change
their their little tingle to that if not
now when
if not now when you guys rise and shine
[ __ ] that's our first story of
the day but I will get to it with you
what do you think about changing good
morning Millennials to rise and shine I
think that's great
and I think we should resize the episode
jacketing everyone is like mimicking
this rise and shine thing and it's like
super hard for me because like why it's
so funny is because Kylie's voice is
terrible and there's just like something
I can't emulate no but it's not even
that it's terrible it's just like it's
so something happens at the end that
didn't ascribable and that you can't
replicate it's like a shift crack it's
like Raja yeah I know but it's like she
didn't play she just was trying to wake
up her daughter him like it she's like
like as opposed to like rise and shine I
feel like it surprised Jane but she we
are [ __ ] delirious also and it's just
it's one of those internet things that
like and it never happens anymore cuz
the Internet is like a garbage cesspool
wasteland but it's one of those things
where it makes you grateful that the
internet exists it's like this is why
the internet exists it is the most
harmless form of internet fun should we
just get into the stories like we
basically okay okay no sounds like we're
drunk but we're not no do you know that
if you podcast more than three hours
like scientifically it's gonna be funny
for anyone who's not in this room is
yeah like that's what I learned this
week on this show also um the podcast
studio that we're currently in is like
an ice box but is anyone else sweating
sweating we were so we were so free we
sat here 10 minutes ago we're like I
would be kepis Oh Dez really
I got [ __ ] chub-rub I'm so sweaty
like I could dye my bras a different
color than it was five minutes ago okay
thank you for for that tidbit the visual
thank you for the visual so we will get
into the stories but I want to bring up
something that
you have obviously forgotten to bring up
but it's so important because last night
we went to dinner at couch la capsula
cachalot and something incredible
happened to Claudia and I just want you
to share with the class because you
clearly forgot I Claude King has gone to
your brain podcasting has gone to my
brain we were leaving catch LA and I got
paparazzi not only did I get paparazzi
but I got TMZ which I have watched TMZ
TMZ is weird because they're like a huge
news outlet and they don't paparazzi
they video paparazzi so they stand out
there and I never knew what it looked
like they this big camera and a huge
light and we walked out the restaurant
and the light went on and I was like oh
who's behind me and they were so by the
way so nice like you expect paparazzi to
be like aggressive like the TMZ guy was
so nice and so funny and I had like a
pet about what he was gonna ask me um
and he was just like what do you have to
say about Cuba Gooding jr. 12 new
accusers and I was like I think it's 14
and we just took a little bit about like
Cuba Gooding jr. being an assailant um
we talked a little about Instagram
Jennifer Aniston I couldn't believe it
and you guys were like getting the car
when I live I could have sit on that
curb talking to TMZ for six more hours I
would watch my titties you were doing so
grating you have to quit while you're
agreed then you just get your foot in
your mouth say something that you regret
and we just had to pull you out of this
situation and in true form the video has
not been posted anywhere I haven't seen
one picture and then because there were
a bunch of paparazzi outside but teams
he was only one who like I guess knew
who I was but then when TMZ wants you
like then everyone else starts taking
your picture because they're like oh we
don't to miss out like maybe this is
just like you know Ricki Lake on a bad
day and then I got packed like a bunch
of other times and of course not one
picture I've seen the light of day but
again if you work in this biz and you
have those credentials keep an eye out
for our girl because we have to find I
feel as though those pictures exist and
we just haven't found them yet I have
tried everything
Craig's pictures were thrown straight
into the garbage memory card it was and
they were changing cards and just
testing their five yeah right those
pictures are no non-existent I do
believe your TMZ like over the shoulder
booty photo getting into the car exists
I almost don't want that photo to exist
because I did not want to be shot from
the back this dress that I was wearing
was so tight and I was wearing the
tightest bra and the tightest banks that
literally my roles had roles like it was
I looked like a loaf of bread from the
back it was rolls on rolls it was a
Rolls Royce okay I'm cruising around La
in a Rolls Royce on my back and I know I
actually don't want that picture to see
the light of day because I look I just
know it's moosie vibe okay I have a
question for you would you rather be
moosie vibes and famous or like sin and
no rolls-royce mousseline smoochy vibes
and famous and I don't even know why I
act like I don't like being a mouse like
I do I'm representing the Meese mousses
and I like it I'm sorry I like I feel
like for a couple months like I was like
really hell-bent on being skinny cuz
like I got really skinny um at the end
of last year and I could look at the TBG
of where's pictures and I'm like so thin
and I've definitely like don't look like
that anymore something in the water at
that night because I look at those
pictures too sometimes and I'm like I'm
like the same weight there that I was at
other times and I just don't look like
that
oh damn thing was electing one thing was
happy guard --less I like recently I
like look at those pictures and I feel
really sad that I don't look like that
anymore but after this trip to LA we're
like everyone looks the same like I look
different and maybe people do take my
pictures because I am fat and you know
what I think it's working like with me
and my brand and I no longer want to be
skinny ok Lucy vibes Lucy vibes openly
like I am a moose and I'm proud and
honestly like I find other people with
the Moosey vibes of course only the ones
strictly with moosie vibes justice for
the mace it's so weird that it's like
goose geese moose yes no gooses mooses
mooses I don't know that's like fish I
don't know but before the Sun comes up
again yeah we need to get into the past
I stories that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast oh and before I do I have
to let everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by attitude
the best and only sheets you need after
sleeping in a hotel sheets for almost a
week I can not wait to get home to my
dog hair filled attitude sheets because
it really makes a huge difference in in
how you sleep and the most important
part is the cooling factor because these
thick like I don't even know what
they're made of Hotel sheets I had not
stopped sweating the back of my neck my
hairs are so curly because I'm sweating
in my sleep so attitude sheets are the
best sheets you'll ever need and the
only month you'll ever need for comfort
is feathery soft when I get into my bed
it's like I could fall asleep so much
faster just because my sheets but really
it's the cooling factor they have
organic clean bamboo and it's extremely
breathable fabric that regulates your
temperature to improve your quality of
sleep the amount of gems I've woken up
in the middle of a night like you would
think I had a nightmare because I'm
drenched like my panties or what like
it's so crazy and ever since attitude
that has not
happen to me anymore and I know why you
like them it's because they're
antimicrobial they've claimed that their
skins appearances has improved after
switching to attitude you can read the
reviews and see for yourself Girish
leads are so important for like your
overall skin care and of course your
temperature but just what you put on you
sleep for so long some of us we try to
at least in like your face is rubbing up
against that stuff it's got to be the
best it's got to be attitude people
don't realize that a lot of skincare
like issues come from dirty sheets and
dirty towels and attitude is better for
the environment their bamboo recycles
night clean bamboo over cycles
ninety-eight percent of the water that
it uses so it's the most sustainable
bedding available they cotton uses a ton
of pesticides and wastewater and it's
very harmful for the environment and I
can't imagine that stuff is good for
your skin either their softest silikal
breathable is linen but at the price of
cotton you're going to love them when
you support our sponsors you get
supported you support our show and right
now our listeners will get 20% off their
sheets and free shipping just text toast
to six four zero zero zero the only way
to get 20% off your set of attitude
sheets and free shipping is to text
toast TOA st to 64000 again that's toast
to six four zero zero zero message and
data rates they might apply unclear but
they might they probably will yeah we
got that attitude if you've ever seed in
Bradford anybody we can't watch a Bratz
movie anymore because we were watching
it when we found out that our dad died
but other than that it would that movie
[ __ ] collapse
ya know honestly even when you find out
you can still watch it without feeling
tricky you could have a traumatic
experience and that's where we learned
the phrase don't get your black guys in
the twist it's just classic stuff you
then also the best part is that the main
Bratz girl her mom is the mom from My
Big Fat Greek Wedding
oh thanks husband says my daughter Mary
eat a meal er it's good stuff and cheese
next up no cheese up no room but she's
got her neck up okay that's like what
they they pull their necks oh yeah pull
my neck three two
that was before face teeth that was
actually a My Big Fat Greek Wedding too
I believe
no I think they had a neck like don't
eat [ __ ] in the whole time that's okay I
make lemon okay are you ready now for
the stories she has you better resin
shine
our first story of the day Kylie Jenner
has gone
taking the internet by storm II Webster
for waking up stormy Webster there are
so many wonderful things coming out of
this I guess the best part is that Kylee
is embracing it more than anyone else
ariana grande wants to sample it Kylie
wants to be in the music video is now
Kylie's Instagram bio it is she just
posted a photo of like sweatshirt saying
rise and shine oh good I don't know if
it's real merch because though it is the
caption this shop Kylie Jenner doc I
know like [ __ ] genius the merch
itself doesn't look like ombre no she
posted another one it's real it's real
okay so we're going to shop today and
then we'll go to shop morning toast on
Monday because we have a restock for
3:00 p.m. Eastern Time what's so weird
about the whole um thing is that this
clip comes from her office tour which
was released two weeks ago
it takes a while for someone to to pick
a nugget yeah I wonder who started it
just someone [ __ ] hilarious rise and
shine rise and shine no it's like
there's a crack in her voice yeah at the
eye and shine it's [ __ ] incredible
Aylin I really do hope I've heard some
good remixes she posted a video to her
Instagram of stormy playing a remix and
it's [ __ ] slaps right ride you hope
that a real song comes out I would go
for a collab Ari and Kylie or like a
Travis Scott Kylie
yeah it's Travis Scott Ari like a real
one car you broken up I think they're
broken up but they're still a family and
I don't think that there's bad blood
either so they probably still hang out
all the time but there's just oh I'm
sorry
you know who needs to get involved in
this Sonya Diplo Diplo Kanye Kanye's
like uh I feel like he's above it like
right now in his own mind
yeah he is in Diplo was really like the
viral the DJ of the internet yes and
it's up to him to like make this a
reality for us if I were to remix it it
would go a little something like this
Roger Tsien Bastian Rosita uh-uh-uh-uh
rise and shine stormy Webster rise and
shine rise rise and shine
- cries - rise - rise and shine - rise
and shine rise and shine Oh
rise and shine shine that is so funny
I didn't know where I was going with
that but I mean I'm happy with where it
went their eyes and try and take you
away
I don't know how any one's gonna wake up
their child ever again
[Music]
I gotta calm bad we gotta go because
every day like you wake someone up and
you say rise and shine like I'm just
it's gonna put a smile on your face you
know and it's such like a popularly used
term for like waking people up that it
has taken over so much it like you
literally cannot wake up your children
and say the words rise and shine rise
and shine without actually singing it
right you could say rises jump we truly
are um anyways I was gonna say one more
thing about rise and shine Oh people are
making it their alarm clocks which is
also like a great way to rise and shine
I'm just like loving how much of the
jenner/kardashian clan is like leaning
into this line I don't know that it
would have had such big leg if Kylie
didn't like get in on the joke
immediately like Cher Ariana Grande
story wanting to be in the music video
if it would have stomped around on its
big feet yeah if Kylie hadn't embraced
it the way I don't know if it would have
you know came down the stairs and it's
Herman Munster shoes Eva Tom makes
mistake oh my god honestly old school
Real Housewives of New York episodes are
some of the greatest things to watch and
it actually is a real testament and we
say this all the time and for some
reason every conversation comes right to
cancel culture but it's like how we
always say like he used to live in such
a different time if you watch some of
the episodes of real houses in New York
like they could not say half the [ __ ]
when LuAnn like reamed out Bethenny oh
no no yeah LuAnn reamed out Bethenny in
front of Bethenny's show for her because
Bethenny chauffeured didn't refer to her
as mrs. de Lesseps but he called her
LuAnn I'm like so rude so classes so
elite it's like that chicken op could
not happen today no it couldn't
okay I never thought I'd say this but
I'm like all
toute for the week about like cancel
culture and the times jegging is fair
speaking of though um my piece with
Entertainment Tonight just came out I
did like a 12-minute interview with them
and it's honestly really good it is good
I mean I look so fat and my pimples
showing and I have a double chin but
like Lucy dives only I mean here you
should just listen to it wait should I
make merch that says Missy my bundling
maybe see how it like it lands yeah
speaking of merch restock Monday 3 p.m.
Eastern Time shot morning toast calm
everything is back go see what the thick
toasters think that's like my sub group
of choice these days I just feel like
it's a safe space for me and if they
want to embrace the Missy vibes I think
we should okay even though like okay are
you ready for our next story because I
think it's one that's gonna get you
riled up and it's a it's some Twitter
drama continued between Holden and I
chillin see I thought it was other
Twitter drama Jamila Jamila Sara Sampaio
oh [ __ ] that was the story I want to
talk about okay okay fine I'm gonna
switch to Gmail Gmail and Sara Sampaio
because that's what I've been meaning to
talk about they are in a Twitter feud
that will not end it will not end it's
like the eeep they each keep trying to
get the last word and nope the other
ones respond then they're each being
like so sjw about everything social
justice warrior and each time I read
their response I'm like she has a point
she has a point yeah I'm like watching a
match of ping pong obviously I think
overwhelmingly people aren't Jameela
Jamil sighs just because she's always
right I said whatever Jameela Jamil says
like I believe her I just like she's a
smartest woman alive but I fell to sell
out that Sara Sampaio like made a decent
point which is like I understand the
video that Jameela Jamil shared was
awesome but she slammed the whole
modeling industry which I'm not like
here like pro modeling industry but like
she slammed the whole modeling industry
in order to like make this celebration
of this video even better and it's like
why couldn't we just celebrate the video
and not slam everyone else no no oh and
her argument isn't necessarily flawed
basically being you don't have to you
know put down another group of people in
order to celebrate another group of
people and that's like kind of where
like the feminist movement is like
divided right now it's like you like
can't be a feminist if you like want to
be a stripper it's like no no being a
feminist is like anyone can do whatever
they want and stripper a it's being a
stripper is empowering like you have to
accept all types of women not just women
who believe what you believe
so I don't think Jameela Jamil was
necessarily right in slamming an entire
group of people or an entire group of
entire
tray made up of mostly women but at the
same time everything she was saying was
completely right yeah no I don't even
think it's that it's just and we do this
all the time on the show so I I don't
think Sara Sampaio is a toaster but it's
like in order to tear someone in order
to build someone up like you're you can
build them up on their own but when you
compare it to something worse you also
are tearing something down in order to
build this thing up and Jamila Jamila
like prides herself on being almost
perfect and that's an imperfect thing to
do it is but at the same time like I
just can't really get behind Sara
Sampaio like defending I know Victoria's
Secret and that's where she lost me in
the argument like her beginning her
first tweet wasn't completely wrong in
in her thinking um but then Jameela
Jamil is like I can't even take you
seriously like you literally represent
like everything that's right the company
that you like love and represent
represents everything that's wrong with
this industry and if they're transphobic
and and they refuse to evolve and she's
and then she's out here like defending
like she's [ __ ] ed Razak's mistress
you know like no coming out and just
sick in my opinion Victoria's Secret is
indefensible completely agreed and
that's why like she doesn't really have
a leg to stand on yeah but say it was a
model who didn't work with you throw a
secret for some reason or another no
like just someone who doesn't work with
fitori secret not everyone does right
with the argument to be made wasn't
wasn't that flawed honestly like we're
so in the weeds here like everyone zoom
out like rise and [ __ ] shine it's
just like you guys are arguing about
like the tiniest minutia of like what
percentage of women in the modeling
industry are setting for it's like
negative body image standards standard
it's like take a step back everyone yeah
no it was very much like and the longer
the tweets go like the less sense
they're not even like reading each
other's responded arguing about like one
specific point and it we got away from
just like the bigger issue and I the way
the video that Jameela Jamil did share
was awesome there's been more fashion
shows like this this should be what
fashion shows are like everyone
celebration on a typical fashion show
everyone like does look miserable and be
you know I'm not even go there they just
don't look like they're having fun
because you're not supposed to smile
yeah like why can't we be dancing down
the runway that's the Chinese so funny
actually is that the first brand to ever
really put on a fashion show where all
the girls looked happy was Victoria
Secret right and like honestly that that
show was the closest to like a
celebration of fashion
but they just refuse to evolve like
what's so great about the video that
Jameela Jamil posted was that it was a
celebration of fashion of different
types of women with different body types
different skin tones and that's really
was fun fun to watch and that's the kind
of feel like what Victoria's Secret was
meant to do in the beginning like it
wasn't a serious fashion show it was
colorful it was bright they had live
performers and they start to have models
of different skin tones but they never
evolved past that like yeah I thought
they were doing the right thing for
having 50 white girls and like two black
girls yeah that ain't it that ain't it
sis um and another critic might have
called it a celebration of humanity but
what's up from any shipment yeah the
greatest showmen ever heard of it
snitches here on the mic she doesn't
have a camera today because I don't know
if you know but she has a sty and she
can't stop talking you know and
everyone's yelling at me when she's
wearing two pairs of glasses do you want
me to show them I look I think you
should come show us your look okay here
come sit we can share a microphone she
is sick sigh today this is her look
snitch on the toast hey guys welcome
back to my vlog this is my look today
snitch shame so I have contacts and I
need to be able to see but a parent
actually I just looked it up because
we're going to dinner later and I want
to if I could be a little bit prettier
and I can wear contacts if absolutely
necessary so I will so I have these
glasses for sight and then I have these
so I don't offend you guys with the sty
on my eye you look glam you look like
since Chamberlain we went to we went to
Bill's coffee you didn't tell them okay
well this is my look and now I'm just
addicted to the payment I don't want to
leave I know you be inside here I know
you can't see it either but underneath
Margo's Alvin she is wearing her
fabletics
oh I am snitch loves fabletics and I
like Publix even though I don't work out
but I'd like to pretend like I'm gonna
work out and that's why I wear fabletics
and only know about it obviously cuz
I've seen the commercials but also
because Mitch influenced me honestly
they're literally the greatest brand
like ever I don't know what I did before
fabletics everyone knows a reco founded
by actress Kate Hudson so honestly if
it's good enough for Kate Hudson it's
like probably good enough for me and the
whole message behind the brand is
stylish gym where that is priced
affordably and fabletics is always
coming to the rescue because all these
sets being sold these days for like $400
it's just not gonna work it's not gonna
work for me like at all
Margit what's your favorite item from
fabletics oh they're biker shorts are so
great because they have pockets so if
like I'm working out and I want to put
like my air pods in the pocket I will so
all you gotta do is take a super quick
60 second style quiz and you'll receive
a personalized
room of peace is specifically catered
towards your own unique style this takes
the guesswork out of what styles are
best suitable for you with just a few
clicks fabletics is doing all the
homework for you and right now our
audience can get to leggings for only
$24 it's a $99 value but as a VIP you
can use your use a special link and
discover your personal favorite type of
leggings from fabletics I love a tight
pair of leggings that goes literally up
to my butt like yeah it can't go high
enough I want to go up to my chin I'm
loving my fabletics
I needed cuter workout clothes and
fabletics is everything and I'm so
excited about this pouncer so that link
is fabletics comm slash tous it's really
worth to become a VIP if you're anxious
to get in shape and feel confident
stepping into your workout routines with
trendy and affordable gym wear or if you
just want to wear gym wear around town
because it makes you feel cool that's me
I highly recommend checking out
fabletics and trust us you do not want
to miss out on their very special offer
of two leggings for only $24 which is a
$99 value when you sign up for a VIP be
sure to check out our favorite leggings
which are the ones with the pocket that
litter go up all the way to my titties
and get them all of their in stock
designs change monthly so make sure to
shop keep checking in all you have to do
is go to fabletics comm slash toast to
take advantage of this deal that's
fabletics dot-com slash toast to get to
leggings for only $24 that's fabletics
comm slash chose the best part is that
there are no commitments to purchase
monthly and free shipping on all orders
over $49 make sure your enter your email
address
to take the style quiz as you'll receive
exclusive discounts and the inside scoop
about new collections that haven't been
released yet go to fabletics a comm
slash toast
again that's fabletics comm slash toast
terms and conditions apply sign-on get
snatched yes are you ready for our next
story I'm excited to get everyone's
taken I'm excited that the snatchers
here no no I'm excited that you're here
because I want to get your take Noah
sent any oh and Alexa ran our Instagram
official after romance rumors
honestly usually when this happens I'm
like so jealous I'm like no one deserves
notice in tinea but me but like he
shaved his hair and I no longer feel
that way about him so honestly she can
have him she can have him I just read in
this article that they're both 22 so I
guess like that makes sense
she's the Internet's boyfriend and she
like got famous has someone score as
being like a girlfriend in like an
Instagram II couple okay remember her
and J they were like so hey Alvarez yes
like made-up like Instagram couples like
they walked so like Helen Owen and her
boyfriend from The Bachelor could thrive
Oh Savannah and Jared OS run in J
Alvarez Vanna and Jared walk I heard
that on Jerry the tumblr Apple you know
who they are on yeah no no oh my god
this from years ago Savannah they were a
tumblr couple they were obviously goals
inspo whatever and I'm pretty I don't
know where they are now they're
definitely not together to have montuno
she has a swimwear line and she's like
dating some random she always has a new
boyfriend and she literally is Alexis
around I think that they're the same
person they look exactly like
interesante I could have seen her with
Noah Centennial she was also on Dancing
with the Stars Alexis friend so honestly
there's hope for you Jax she interesting
factoid she was partners with Hannah
Browns partner Alan Burstyn and they
dated for show or like they pretended
like they did but he liked their
packages was that my kissing and stuff
Wow yeah that is crazy
whoa whoa Margo do you feel like of all
the couples like who have fake dated
like nikki bella's totally real right
big time because it happened after the
show if it happened after the show it's
real who has pretended besides Alexis
Fran that's the only one that I know I'm
a new dancer what the star stands you
know I'm not I don't have an
encyclopedia of knowledge but as far as
I know I guess then and I mean the
realest couple of them all Robert and
Kim OH
true they took that fake relationship
stuff are they even got married yeah and
they're still carries yeah she got me
she got me a minute mm-hmm that was cute
really cute they're like one of those
couples who like I find cute but I like
don't really like him like to forget how
they met it's like a Britney aldeen
thing it's like they're cute now but
like let's me not forget he left his
wife of like a million years they were
on a break who Robert and his wife they
were separated he was really depressed
Kim came into his life intern thing well
that's Roberts side of the story I'm
sure shower and or whatever her name is
I'm sure showering and her divorce
settlement are fine no I'm sure they're
fine I'm just saying like with
successful men it's like I always love
how certain men have the same wife as
when they got successful as they did
when they when they first started cuz it
shows like money didn't change them and
it's like Robert Herjavec I think it did
change him he was in my cell cycle class
this week what was it was he good I
don't know I saw him after the fact he
was super sweaty she must have been
snitch Arabic oh yeah
snitch Hardwick she's a big she's a big
star huge okay I'm worried that like us
sharing a mic in effect by the way it's
hot it's hot under the studio light I am
so hot and that was it from snitch
Chamberlain Herjavec are you okay oh my
god
okay you guys we're losing our minds we
have to keep going we're gonna power
through next story in some streaming
wars news
AMC Theaters is launching a streaming
service in the latest blow to Netflix
okay I heard and when I first heard it
I'm like damn it's a good idea they're
gonna have movies in theaters at home
but it's not that oh it's not I don't
think it was I don't think so
it will allow members of its loyalty
program to rent or buy films and watch
them at home the first such offering
from a cinema operator that is what it
is no but it doesn't say movies that are
in theaters just any movie it's like a
it's like a blockbuster digital excuse
me yeah oh my god and by the way this is
not even affecting the streaming worse
this is the loser idea ever
totally also didn't Fandango now allow
you to rent movies that were in theaters
and watching them at home there are
that's how I watched Bohemian Rhapsody
and then I told someone that and then
they were like that can't be true and
they went to check in and it wasn't true
no there's like a few apps like Vudu
like random movie apps that you can
watch in theater movies online and it's
it's there's no one platform that it's
like oh if I want to go see a movie in
the theaters but watch it at home I'm
gonna go to this place that doesn't
exist and I thought that this that's
what this was gonna be and that would
have been like a real missed opportunity
but I guess then AMC would be then
putting themselves out of business
I guess so honestly if I had known that
that isn't what this was then I wouldn't
have chosen it as a story just like
here's some streaming more news from
like The Biggest Loser you know like
here's some streaming wars new from the
new platform that's not gonna affect the
streaming wars whatsoever okay well the
streaming wars are poppin like we got
Netflix Hulu the oh geez
we got HBO plus it's coming to 0 soon
they released the titles it's literally
every Disney movie ever released in
theaters in the last 100 years literally
from the nineteen hundreds any Disney
Channel original movie any Disney
Channel remake so it's like I think
Herbie Herbie fully loaded come from
like a long line of Herbie movies
because when they were announcing they
when they announced all the titles they
went chronologically so there was like a
Herbie movie from the 1950s I was like
I'm wearing fan of lalu fully loaded but
that's just me lalu Philly
oh yeah oh they won't get that joke okay
until Monday just come back to it but
obviously all the D coms like I was so
shocked I cannot believe and they
released all the titles in such an
interesting way they did it all on
Twitter yeah pretty cool but like
biggest threat ever ever they do I guess
there's a max to how many times you can
reply to a threat it's 150 because they
had to make like four different threads
well whatever the color of friendship oh
my god whatever they need to do to get a
supreme iam content like I could not be
more excited Tuck Everlasting oh my god
and we were drunk and Eve receive you
put it out there it comes back to you
incredible Victor Garber see you in
mid-november on Disney oh my god do you
know what else is gonna be on there Juno
is gonna be on there um
Roz oh my god like just the song of the
century yeah it's good it's gonna be
huge for Disney acts
I think so too is he Plus at Disney pond
I can't keep up jo Mad Max Disney Plus
Apple Plus Apple watch oh no applesauce
yeah oh that's it yeah yeah
Apple sorrow actually think it's apple
pie Oh morning show is coming on apple
pie is the new snitch Momoa shows also
update from the last time that we spoke
about Jennifer Aniston's Instagram we
spoke about it the night before the
episode came out and she was at 4 and a
half and were like oh she'll probably be
a 5 as of today she's at 11 million
followers
she broke the world record she beat the
Royals when the world joined Instagram
hey Henry I remember that record
whatever it is and now it's Jennifer
Hamson like who'd have thought not me
definitely not me I would have lost that
bet okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story it is a little bit of
business to round out the week we
haven't hit you with some business
because obviously we're so la like we're
so bad and we've only been caring about
celebrities but I have some hard dating
business that I think is pertinent to
the [ __ ] situation through
tests and intuition as well dude you
ready for it yeah you don't look ready
I'm ready okay
female c-fos brought in 1.8 trillion
dollars more than their male peers
female CEOs are killing the game you
know people's like I just female CEOs
are out earning their male counterparts
people say it's because you know the bar
is higher for them they have more to
prove expectations are higher and
just crushing it look at these you hear
this female CEO yeah because people love
to say like we would have a female CEO
but they underperform that is no longer
a valid reason companies looking for a
better financial return should consider
a female chief financial officer within
the first 24 months of appointing female
CFOs company saw on average a six
percent increase in profits and an eight
percent better stock return compared to
performance under male powered Assessors
these women brought in 1.8 trillion
dollars of additional cumulative profits
according to a study by S&P bloke global
market intelligence the researchers
looked at 6,000 companies on the Russell
3000 over the last 17 years
his Russell's daughter a toaster good
Russell what's good this is just like
more proof that we need it you know like
I feel like a lot of times companies
love to like lie and be like you know we
had a woman but like it's like they
always put women CEOs and oh that's what
I learned from younger remember they're
bringing yeah bringing on that uh that
writer who wrote a book about how women
in like high power positions the
statistics say that they underperform
but it's really because they only give
him the job and like the company's in
the [ __ ] and then they're like we
need a big change how about a woman and
then she'd had her inherit this [ __ ] of
a company yes I'm gonna that's so funny
that we learned that from younger but
now this is further this is just more
proof that it's like if a man can do it
a woman can do it and she probably could
do it better and she's percent better
and we're doing it better here on a
morning toast I'm speaking of doing
things better before we bring out tisha
I must talk about our new sponsor
seriously it's the best thing that ever
happened to me embark it's the best
thing ever we must talk about it before
you shove away before we bring out tisha
also I just realized the word in Park
it's a genius name for the company
because it's bark it's a it's for dogs
this company might be my favorite
company ever like it's one of those
things where it's like I can't I mean I
thought of this in my own mind please
tell them what it is Claude because I
can't sit on this company any longer
it's a DNA kit for your dog so I got one
last week I had to put the q-tip in the
bottom like pouch of Theo's cheek he
literally tried to eat the q-tip it was
so hard on Mike you [ __ ] you just take
this q-tip for like 30 seconds it
actually wasn't that hard and you put it
in the tube it's just like any other DNA
cut test but it's for your dog and then
you can come back and get a ton of
information about their breed
obviously like health stuff which is
like less interesting but still very
important um but it's like I'm waiting
to see if the a was a descendent of
Royals because I believe that he is but
if you add I mean your dog more like you
haven't gotten your results yet but I
can tell you 100% like he just took a
DNA test and he is a hundred percent
Russian yeah we already know where he
comes from you know what if you accept
if you adopt a dog or if your dog's a
stray and you don't know what type of
breed he is like this is how you find it
out it's like sometimes also interest
I'll have someone there like well I'm
like what kind of dog is it like we
don't know we adopted him and like
there's just no paperwork on it so this
is the kind of genius knowledge is power
you guys the embark dog DNA tests test
kit is the most comprehensive kit on the
market looking at over 250 breeds and
170 genetic health conditions to help
you best care for your dog embark is the
only research grade dog DNA test test
kit on the market they analyzed a
hundred times more genetic information
than any other DNA test on the market
this means that their scientists look at
200,000 genetic makers and can
scientific discoveries that can help all
of our dogs have longer healthier lives
like if I get it back and it doesn't say
that because perfect like I don't know
what I'm gonna do I mean it will say
that and that he's like a Russian doctor
it is the best in class dog DNA test
it's a number one highest rated by
customers I so far I'm waiting for my
results but so far it's been a breeze oh
and they pay for the shipping on the box
back because like if something doesn't
have a prepaid label like I can't I
cannot be involved it's developed by
PhDs and veterinarians for your dog
and they know your dog's breed to learn
how to best care for your pup so if you
have a dog and like certain breeds are
disposed to like different types of like
Theo's a king Charles Cavalier and
they're predisposed to heart conditions
like if I didn't know that he was a
Cavalier like I wouldn't be able to feed
him properly or like his he has to eat a
specific type of food it's just really
important and not enough people know
about it
they have exclusive holiday offer
because it's a great gift for like a
psycho dog mom you can't get it anywhere
else to go to embark vet calm now use
the promo code toast to save 15% off
your dog DNA test test kit visit it's
hard to say dog DNA test kit embark vet
dot-com promo code toast that's e/m ba
RK v ET dot-com promo code toast it's
really premium and I really feel like
everyone's gonna be excited about it he
just took a DNA test turned out he's a
hundred percent rush even when he's
fleeing countries yeah he
got heart problems that's a human that's
the puppy in him
bling-bling that he solves them that's
the doctor in him come on a bad [ __ ]
non-committal loving with your medicine
just a little down but they're holding
him back and that's the sound Harvey you
back a bargain you back
I have literally sweatin every crevice
of my vagina like I've got to go home
we're gonna bring out tisha yeah she's
right over there
we're gonna sit down talk about JPJ
reminder that there is a merge restock
Monday 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time in
addition to an episode being dropped
with the Queen Lauren Elizabeth where we
are announcing something super exciting
I am hitting up San Diego tonight
tickets available girls no job calm and
San Francisco and the six new shows that
I released are now officially on sale
tickets available at girl with no job
dot [ __ ] com we love you guys
thank you for bearing with us this week
and through this episode I hope you
think it's as funny as we do sitting
here we've loved LA we've loved LA week
now it's time to get the [ __ ] home we
will see you in New York on Tuesday but
before that we will see you here again
on Monday love you all very much to
follow me on instagram episode please
I'm so sweaty
bye we are back we are honored humbled
and blessed to be sitting down with the
Bachelorette and paradise herself I know
when the cold thought she was the
bachelor in paradise it's not but it was
actually Taoiseach Adams I'm so excited
that you're here I can't leave you
haven't been on the show before just
cause like we talked about you all the
time it's like you're basically here
with us I feel like I know you guys we
know you we you know us I'm so happy
that you're here I just this is an honor
thank you for coming no this is not for
me so obviously we just need to make
sure like everything's cool with you and
JPJ before we get started because we
like ship you two so hard yeah the
couple we didn't really need it you guys
were just dating good lemon livin life
did you see reality seed posted a like
spoiler that you two had actually broken
up you know that reality Steve I'm so
down with him yeah and you know what
he's like annoying but he's usually
right but he was totally wrong which I
love yeah telling me what I'm doing so I
could tell you you're in a row you're
like you're wrong it was so we all right
yeah you guys are cool is he moving to
LA he is that's the word on the street
yeah he'll be here pretty soon
oh my gosh it's hard to maintain a
relationship East Coast West Coast
different time zone
I mean we literally live on FaceTime
right and that's not live it's not it
I've seen him a select few of times
since we started dating so it's just
we're just figuring it out yeah I know
we're gonna get a lot of questions um
once this episode airs about where your
shirts from okay because it's so cute
kinu Shelburne where it's from Thanks
it's from this little boutique um it's
called a shop love Lola okay it's in
Costa Mesa okay how 17th Street
definitely get it it's like it's so cute
thank you you look great you're just
shining like like you have sprung onto
the scene from Colton season and just
from the get-go like we everyone knew
you were special you know yeah and then
you really shined on that season even
though there was just like not a lot
going on for you to shine in and I'm so
glad you made it out of there live
because then you have to shine on
paradise and paradise for me seems like
the hardest worst thing to do like
sweating on camera trying to fall in
love first of all I love heat didn't
sweat oh really highly arrived I I love
he for a lot of people by like week
three like the skin is bad like the hair
is bad but you look really great the
whole time the spading suits were fresh
thank you I will say my skin freaked out
a ton on paradise did it didn't know it
was it didn't pick it was the worst
really oh I've never I really thought I
was a teenager I guess it's a lot of
makeup all day all day every day and
it's hot and then it's just like I'm
literally sleeping outside yes my
pillows are like wet from humid well you
got home what was like the first thing
you did back in civilization I threw
everything in the wash yeah I threw away
all my makeup and all antenna stuff what
else did I do take a shower I yeah and
then I made myself a margarita yes I was
then addicted to she talked about the
whole drinking on paradise did you wake
up every day and have a drink what time
did you have a drink it's like you're
tempted to be you know so drunk because
there's open bar and it's there all the
time but then at some point I'm sure it
gets like old and you don't even want to
drink anymore yeah I mean you know I
don't wake up and have a drink in fact
we had the best cooks like I had a green
juice almost every morning yeah you can
make anything you want so I had a green
juice had an omelet um what did I do I
would probably start drinking the
afternoon it was always the first person
to like get the during harvest
started and I think I was one of them
that is Tiffany and how was Wells as a
bartender he was actually great heavy
pour he could have done a little bitter
oh really
yeah that's Larry we were always just
trying to hit his hand just a little
more yeah he has to abide by all the
world's regulation at exactly so so many
people came and went
bachelor in paradise you were first on
the beach and he pretty much made it to
the last episode right our second to
last episode yeah I was I think it was
like the fifth girl but yes I mean it -
right before engagements and so how long
is that actually in real person time um
it's a couple of weeks it's like three
weeks does it feel longer I literally
thought I was there for three and a half
months four months there way longer than
bachelor yeah yeah it was the most
insane thing I've ever done no phones no
phones no amenities - I could not wait
to get my phone right like was there
anything news going on where like you
just didn't even know like there was
like a hurricane or something like how
would you know name me in the fina yeah
from civilization is actually kind of
scary it is in fact when I was on The
Bachelor that's when like the fires were
all happening over here in LA yeah so I
kind of like no like being disconnected
on the show and you're like oh my gosh
what's going on at home it's so crazy
but no nothing when nothing crazy no no
nothing was going on just everything
crazy going on on to be oh my gosh too
much to handle you were caught up in
many a cholo roam and yeah here at the
morning toast like we did think that you
and Derek were endgame and obviously we
were morally yeah I don't know I just
assumed you guys like we're engaged
right now she told us that so I was just
like watching it through the lens of
being like okay obviously tation Derek
end up together I know it's like he's
going home and I'm like you were suppose
when our year ago in the back and I
wasn't I wasn't that upset because like
I feel like at the end of all this like
me and Derek are actually the most
compatible okay I'm okay with it I'm not
you really happy for you and JPJ like I
think it's gonna be good for you thank
you can you talk about living the
experience then watching it on TV like
I'm sure everyone is making comments
like oh you should have done this you
should have said this you should
got more involved you should have gotten
less involved how do you deal with like
having to have a million people watch
like your very personal intimate
relationships being growing it's kind of
hard just cuz they you don't see
everything and I know everyone says this
time and time again you see like four
hours worth of a 20 up at my barber -
yeah but like it's true like so much
goes on like you see a select
conversation like even when we were I
don't know making fun of like Angela's
walk literally everybody was doing that
right okay and he was just lighting a
thing looks really bad it made me look
like I was just trying to like rag on
her and be like some mean girl yeah come
on and that was a great dancing also
there's no TV there's no music there's
no book like what do you think I'm gonna
do of course I'm gonna make fun of y'all
make me like I'm gonna make up all of ya
that's a fair assessment then I actually
did get over it yeah
and the wedding seemed like the greatest
thing ever because you guys finally got
to leave oh my gosh you have no idea
like you know you would be going to a
wedding like - no tell you to pack a
dress because they should have they did
tell us to bring like you always just
know to bring like a formal option right
even like for a rose ceremony you could
do a rose on a dress - exactly which
mine was a rose ceremony dress so it's
like I felt so underdressed I should
have wore the dress that I wore to the
previous rose ceremony to the wedding
but you would you yeah yeah like they
should give people warning otherwise
like Chris and Krystal it's like people
are coming in new dresses yeah yeah see
I literally had a beach maxi dress we
heard of the group that got to go into
the wedding yeah okay as a viewer I have
to tell you how [ __ ] awkward that was
to watch it was like it was literally
like high school like to call people the
plastics and the losers like oh we got
to go
and it was probably stuff because like
it looked like so much fun like it would
have been fun regardless but coming from
the [ __ ] house just deserted island
oh you hang on for two weeks like it was
probably so fun like even more
heightened fun it's like dance music
civilization honestly so when you got
back was it like so [ __ ] awkward glad
everyone was sleeping okay and we had
our shoes rear off cuz we just got bit
partying and we're like oh okay well I
guess I'll go to bed now right yeah when
you see all the losers like sitting by
the bar
dad yeah everyone's like so how was the
party like the next day I'm just like
yeah interesting dynamic that we hadn't
had before and I so appreciated it and
then the wedding content like made for
so many good storylines and then having
people come down at the wedding it added
a new layer that I was loving I had no
idea all those people were gonna be
there first of all it was really weird
walking to like a wedding reception
we're like you knew of everyone but you
don't know did you introduce yourself to
like other bachelor nation people who
like you know and they know but of
course of course Mike my favorite was
probably well I met a lot of people but
I loved Raven and I loved reason you
know in an atom and it was just so funny
because like Raven comes up to me and
like Adams like hiding behind her she's
like I said to tell you like Adams like
your biggest in the back it was just so
chase so sweet you guys are the cutest
thing yeah they really are Nichole put
it best it's really like a class reunion
yeah people from different grades who
like you know of cuz you saw them in the
hallways but you didn't really get a
really good way to put it yeah yeah can
I get your take on something speaking of
Nichole you two are close yes yes so if
you could just like relay a message sure
is it's like I actually really respect
her because she did a lot of really
cringey things and like in her defense
in her defense like she was there for a
while a lot of heightened emotions and
like she was being crazy saying crazy
things like calling herself about trying
paradise right and like forcing these
two guys to get into a fight overheard
them being like he's aggressive watch do
that like she was just like a little all
over the place and she got a lot of like
tweets like making fun of her and she
really took it in stride and it's very
hard to like make fun of yourself and
then I got and like left with everyone
instead of having them laugh at you so
for that I really respect her but she's
now continuing all this drama it's like
this was months ago get over it
girlfriend like grace they they want to
get engaged which is like you and JP
Jaden get engaged isn't that crazy like
it's people who do get engaged they know
that it's right and like look at Kristen
crystal like it really can work out but
it's not that crazy at all so much to
not want to get engaged after three
weeks looking for even Adam you know you
don't have to get engaged but you can
mind up engaged so it wasn't so crazy I
think what the problem is is that they
actually have like a much bigger story
line while we were there then what what
was shown okay so I think it's just like
a lot more history that like
took place like I'm not gonna lie to you
clay Nicole were the cutest things I've
ever seen
really like the cutest thing and all the
doubts that like we're sprinkled in in
little testimonials on on Clay's part
weren't present on the beach they
weren't and that you saw me call him out
yeah it's cuz I saw and he wasn't being
like truthful and so I was just and I
just like I don't mean to be like a
little investigator but like when it
comes to like my girlfriend's like yeah
I got you and also I have a some pretty
good relationship history yeah so I kind
of like I don't know red flag it's kind
of trigger me yeah and you're you're
willing to just say it yeah they like
this oh wow
but so now there's more drama unfolding
in the comments section on Instagram I
saw that isn't Nicole in a relationship
no was she with someone else talking to
someone but a boyfriend to know okay
with her Instagram captures rooming it
seemed like she found someone who liked
appreciated and respected her he was
very sweet you know yeah um but so I
just do you feel like at some point it's
like enough like like like she should
like let it die yeah like things take
time and then clay made a funny joke and
yes he we ignited the fire but I thought
it was funny well things take time
except engagements in Paradise because
it was on his picture I know I know I
know Nicole's like can you just have two
AP day like burn that photo down yeah
but yeah I think it's like dead and gone
and she just kind of just kind of move
on we got a lot of questions about how
you refer to JPJ like what do you call
it now that you guys are like intimate
like do you call him JPJ you call him
Johnny come John Paul Jones I call him
John John when I want I feel like fine
and like for yoga JPJ yeah yeah you know
but it's John and so funny because like
when I was interviewing like wow being
on paradise I'd like yeah so John told
me that's like who's John I'm like John
Paul Jones oh my god that's so funny if
you said John I wouldn't know who you're
talking about but so funny like yeah
it's weird to meet but yes he's John
what did you do before you were on The
Bachelor what was your career
I was a phlebotomist Oh what's her it's
like job line oh my god that is so scary
like did you see the movie the
documentary about Sarah no yes as a
phlebotomist how did you feel about but
i I've heard of it I'd never watched
that was it about she sees me out
she was the Billy McFarland of the
medical industry and she had this whole
big plan that like huge investors got
behind where she would get a prick of
blood just the smallest sampling like a
blue
and you could test for you put in her
little fairness machine and it test for
every single disease under the Sun and
as a phlebotomist you would know that
that's impossible impossible because you
need so much blood you need so much
samples but she was going about it and
she was selling this machine to
Walgreens blah blah blah but it didn't
[ __ ] work and it was it was like
unsanitary and the Walgreens people were
just drawing blood in the real way and
testing it and then saying they were
using Thera knows economists you should
watch you should went home you know what
a chi leak really creeps me out oh yeah
you and the boy like she like really
creeps yeah guys just kinda like bug out
she's gonna be a popular Halloween
costume yeah sure okay nicely thankful
that off please
yeah all you need is electronic okay um
so are you planning on going back to
work like your life has changed so much
in like it's like this new culture that
we're living in where it's like you
really don't ever need to work after
being on the bachelor or bachelorette
and it's a career shift I mean I guess
but like I went straight to work to my
nine-to-five the second I go back from
botching you did of course he's and then
working a 95 no I quit right before I
went to Paris off it was like just weird
it's just like I was leaving all the
time and it wasn't for out of the
company wasn't fair to me like I felt so
overwhelmed about not getting stuff done
and I just had to like quit but I was
going to be a phlebotomist because I
want to go to PA school I'm a bio
pre-med major so that's what I wanted to
do but honestly that was my passion my
passion now is more like in homes in
architecture and like oh that's so
interesting question for you are you in
J PHA gonna dress up together for
Halloween you know what we've definitely
thought about it we have some cute idea
do you
yeah you're gonna say that you know
we're really good we tell us afterwards
yeah okay we I need some inspiration
okay yeah um can you talk about the time
you spent at home after you left
paradise before going to see JPJ like
what did you do like what did you feel
what made you get on that plane did you
have to you know tell producers like yo
meet me at the house I'm getting on a
plane you know what L justic what's
funny is okay Paradise was a lot I kind
of like lock myself in my room like I
usually do after being on a TV show yeah
so it was just quite a bit and like all
I can think about was just like John and
I was like we had a really good thing
going but we started Midway so what it
really wasn't we didn't give enough time
and so it's like what if something like
good came out of it and like I didn't
know yeah but also my sister was going
to school in Maryland so she was moving
to go to Pensacola Florida cuz she's
been coming up pilot Oh cute yeah that's
her also smart yeah
so I was gonna go and say goodbye
because she was moving so then I was
like by the way John lives like 30 right
away and like I guess I could just go
hop over wasn't too big
I kind of told one my producers that I
was really close with and I was like you
know what I just I think this is what I
need to do he's like this could be
really good and like I'm really excited
for you so we're gonna send a camera
crew like my ticket was Ricky Bahl like
we got it and yeah they just came with
their thirst knows no bounds I mean they
were only there for like probably 18
hours like they just facility facility
being there when he opened the door was
that a genuine reaction or you should
refilm it uh that was a genuine reaction
but they kind of cut it out he just
started laughing of course he did cuz
that's just what he doesn't he sees me
he goes haha yeah do you feel like the
like everyone on bachelor in paradise
knowing that like at the end is the
engagement like it kind of affects
relationships like maybe not in the best
way like even with clay and Nicole I
feel like if the engagement was never a
question like they might've had a chance
to survive outside of the show but
because like she was so keen on
engagements and he wasn't and the fact
that it was even a conversation like
really might have doomed them ya know I
think that definitely had an effect if
they could have just kept dating nope
that yeah if engagement wasn't like the
main premise they would probably still
be dating yeah interesting out of all
the couples who got engaged which do you
think is gonna be the first to the altar
or the only ooh I don't know I think
Hannah and Dylan I didn't have the
cutest thing they're really out here
doing it I most you know I don't know I
don't know I love Demi and Christian
them yeah well I'm actually heard they
broke up can you confirm Roger neither
that is true because I don't know I I
shared that they weren't together I'm
gonna get your temperature on Chris and
Katie and what were your thoughts on the
incredib
we have an interview and situation they
had on after the final rose and I am a
Katy Stan like I loved her and I just
don't know what happened at that last
I'll sell apart it was so awful like now
when we were there filming it kind of
just like all happened we had no idea
that was gonna happen do you feel
awkward yeah a little bit in the sense
of like we wanted to like help and we
kind of felt like we were like in like a
like a terribie session yeah and like I
was just like shoot like don't feel that
way but like Chris I love you and like
Brett it was just like I was very
involved yeah I'm gonna make it I hope
you do yeah yet I really don't like a
garden gate I was like who's the third
couple but we haven't heard about them
like and inside no news is good news no
news is it's true but like Dylan and
Hannah they were traveling around the
world like I know that they're together
because I see them in a hotel room
together you know right yeah I just much
seen so much of the other two couples
that I just just genuinely don't know if
they're still together
you know I don't know I think Chris for
sure and Katie are together okay I think
that first I'm almost positive that I
mean Christian or not which would be so
sad and so crazy because I really
enjoyed watching their journey oh lord
have mercy
yeah um let's talk drama like the kid
the show's over okay who were we friends
with who don't we like who weren't who
do you still keep in contact with
where's the beef the group chat in the
middle of all the Kailyn brought
Blakeley gamma-x try have heard the
group chat it's nothing but it's not
favorable yeah okay so drama I still
talk to everyone from the most part I
don't leave there's nobody that I'm like
you didn't really have a lot of peas
yeah just like made one comment about
Hanna ji and is that what you wanted me
to say Snatcher
but like you were just saying what
everyone else was thinking so but I
didn't might look like you're you didn't
mean girl her know her reaction was very
dramatic I remember that it was a little
much yeah but no I didn't mean to do the
most with her right like she thought
someone had to say it but also they yeah
we were all thinking of it right I don't
know your point was so true they brought
you into a situation and took up your
time in those early key moments on the
beach that wrapped involved you with
Blake and you miss those opportunities
to make connections with other people
sure in the most important time in like
she knew that for you and let you go on
that date and I felt you well guys did
tell me they're like yeah after the
first date we thought you and Blake
really good things so we kind of like
backed off right but like am I gonna go
you know like come on but I do need to
commend you
or how you handle that entire situation
because I think when you guys went on
the date at first I'm like oh no this
[ __ ] is now getting caught up in all
the drama when like I really feel like
you're so above it and you found out
that there was something weird going on
and you just washed your hands and
including yourself in this narrative but
you never has to be a part of needs too
much and you just like really washed
your hands of it and never looked back
and I just thought that was like so
mature of you because like paradise and
the environment kind of creates this
sort of you know situation where you
like want to get even in more and deeper
fighting could I talk to you for a
second and you just bounce the [ __ ] out
and you and Blake were never even a
question like and I'd loved that yeah
yeah I just feel like you know he had
enough on his plate and I did not ask to
be involved in like the spider out of
stuff so I was just like peace deuces
you did a great job thank you when you
got home and you were watching the
episodes and everyone's tweeting you
were pretty like a nun controversial
figure so I'm sure it wasn't terrible
but people always have things to say oh
he's really negative yeah I'm an even
someone like you who was just like truly
a ray of sunshine on the show and really
did nothing wrong and never had like a
moment where you probably are got I'm
sure you still got an influx of nasty
DMS tweets yeah it was more so after the
whole like Angela thing oh really yeah
what it what how do you people were just
like tisha I thought so highly of you
for you to stoop down that I'm like
Hello because I like I hate Nicole's
head down like rub on everybody I'm on a
pedestal like just chill for a minute
and no and they just expect everyone to
be perfect and that's so crazy and by
the way like you're still perfect even
though you did this yeah I didn't do
anything wrong right no and she did walk
weird come on yeah it was aggressive
walk it was it was a struggle up for a
wedding I mean I went to a wedding right
after and the bridesmaid was like I want
to be like Angela walking down the aisle
like angels a sweet girl so I don't want
people to think like thank you yeah like
relax we got so many questions about
your teeth like why well they're so
white it's so funny this girl sawed me
at the airport please just tell me why
your teeth or what horrific they're
seemingly perfect funny I don't I don't
I you Sensodyne toothpaste so check it
yeah do you have sensitive teeth a
little bit yeah
gums yes yeah we also got like a lot of
positive positive comments about your
body and your breasts specifically but
I'm not out here objectifying women but
it's one let you know like it was all
very well received and you can be very
proud yeah very much I got them done
when I was in high school money
well-spent my god yes my doctor's name
is G OD never going boobs down my boobs
are all natural they're all so you got
them in high school when you develop I
was like high schools a little young
like anime who's dr. JA Derek Derek you
know I'm we've deemed like a time or two
I think he like made fun of me about
something like we're like we're good
yeah we're fine when you watch back
those episodes of JPJ really defending
your honor like being a little nuts yes
I make you feel I mean I know Jon had
like the best intention but I mean we
talked about it he was extremely
apologetic for the way that he acted I
think it was just a little much but like
also try being on like two hours of
sleep it's so much like he really mean
and is doing this to 24 hours a day like
you kind of just over react to things
yeah yeah I want to ask you a few
questions before you like we let you go
about Colton season okay and I actually
don't remember this incident but this is
a question from s Calvin the most
important question why did you decide to
jump feet first on the bungee jumping
date with Colton as if I made that as a
consciousness just okay I was blacked I
cannot believe it was gone oh yeah so
you're supposed to go had furniture I
was just like mom yeah and I just was
like I had a lesson for like 20 minutes
like right this is what you're supposed
to do do not do this no like okay got it
it was an option for you to say no would
they have let you not do it like has
anyone ever gotten down off the bungee
jump you know I thought that and I was
like they're gonna for sure tell me to
go home but then their relationship
wouldn't have grown if you guys know
true because like honestly ii got down
and we were just happy to be alive
oh my gosh if i saw
I like Pat okay so I passed out midair
that's why I like did you have to back I
was like you don't I was gone I was not
there how did you not like fracture your
spine my dad literally lectures me about
this every single day
dictation do you move that one time a
guest daddy we died remember today oh my
god that's so funny and you mentioned on
the beach that Colton was actually a
terrible kisser oh did you hear from him
at all no no no but didn't he like tweet
something he always takes to Twitter
right now with Rachel Lindsay what are
your thoughts have you met Rachel I have
not actually we were just with her and
we asked her and she said she loves you
she thinks you're right oh that's sweet
I did a little bit of a podcast with her
she's doing best I think she's really
sweet
um and Colton is now inserting himself
in some drama I would love to know like
I'm just having known like what the The
Bachelor ecosystem is like where do you
stand with Colton between Colton and
Rachel Holden in general like using his
Twitter as a defense mechanism I mean I
think Rachel's a straight shooter and I
think Colton does rely on Twitter to
kind of like yeah take his little jabs
honestly Colton's like a little french
bulldog he's not gonna like do anything
yeah yeah I mean yeah I think I'm wants
to maybe on my side only no yes I don't
want to be on the side I understand
before we let you go I don't want to
know what kind of bra you wear it's
Victoria Secrets trap really mm the one
that has like a little V in the middle
with like a little diamonds cute okay I
mean she's not real diamonds bullying oh
it's not we loved you we loved watching
you we can't wait to see you on our TV
sometime soon like I don't know maybe
you televise wedding I don't know I
don't know valo to shawn instagram at
tisha with how many a's at the end
there's three wow that was very brave of
you I'm so sorry
well I was taste chef a for Adams and
then I don't know the last egg it came
from it's for extra love you thank you
guys so much for watching toast la week
we really hope you liked it we will be
back on Monday with an episode with
Lauren Elizabeth with a very special
announcement there and an update on our
merch restock spoiler alert it's Monday
at 3 p.m. Eastern Time have an amazing
weekend don't drink and drive and have a
great time Klaus law bye